okay good earlier my mouse was yet again
acting up it is back to the old the old
mouse and I have made an adjustment with
the old mouse the adjustment being the
mouse speed so I'm still trying to get
used to the speed for sure like right
there you'll be seen that the one minute
tournaments if I end up doing it should
be a blast a blast to watch as I fumble
with moving my pieces okay what is the
big bad scoop here this is happening
isn't it it certainly is you know what I
might be able to do I'm thinking about
this night move mmm try that my main
intention here what I'm trying to do is
maybe trap this Bishop and I know
there's this pawn push but I could give
a check and I think boom boom boom the
bishop would be trapped sneaky stuff ah
isn't this Bishop gonna be trapped I
think it is let's see trapper ruski
unavoidable
my Queens protected so I mean I could
push here
you know I think this is working however
I messed up I should have taken the
night first you know what's going to
happen now you know what's gonna happen
mmm yepper I should have just taken this
night first and then played c5 and
everything would have been perfect I
would it of okay well what do you do
here
ah let's see back up the bishop and meet
efore with h3 and meet Bishop h5 with g4
let's give that a shot
let's give it a whirl his berries I
guess there's no he's not going anywhere
but um I that I think there was just
like a cleaner way why wasn't I know
we're aware of that it's is not a good
start no it's not come on you could get
out of this pin now can't you in between
hmm
okay I believe you just do this let me
just double check though g4 is f5 gonna
be played I should I should be able to
defend this it's a typical idea to try
and get out of the pin oh wait a second
hahaha better but take that Bishop hang
on okay let's do this so now I'm down to
peace and do I take that bishop no
actually I could do that I could take
that bishop I really don't want to so
we play here I take the bishop the file
opens up i don't want the file to open
up um he's not going anywhere so I'll
get that piece back but the material be
even what can you do I think everything
should still be okay even should I
capture that I just I don't know what I
want to do what do I want to do ah man
okay well candidate moves i'm thinking
you like backing the bishop pop if i go
here there's Bishop b4 hmm
yeah I better just take F takes is
happening I guess just Queen g3 is
defend stuff look at this dummy this
bishop on c1 it's seen better days let
me tell you now hopefully this night
can't turn out to be a giant pain
oh man okay so this is not a cool start
at all not cool um like I take him yet
um not sure why let's get this rook
involved now I'm ready to take and maybe
push the night away and get to see seven
my queen is converging on this square
sad piece and I should prob okay now I
should probably take them right now and
they get to see seven this is actually
working out get some get a Pawnee back
and on this see file but wow does my
bishop remain ugly yes sir ugly bishop
on d 2 i'd like to get in b5 Bishop b4
but that's dropping 83 so after crooks
e7 if the Queen well should the Queen
can't make use of d6 what's black
thinking about by the way shouldn't be
this no matter what as otherwise like I
take I'm on the night oh there's that I
don't know that that's working though I
think it's actually losing more material
because now i get this move in with
tempo and now Bishop b4 is coming so
that's a
that's a problem right that's a problem
all right let's do this
and after the Queen was I have that rook
so that's excu going down there actually
that rook isn't going anywhere take this
first rook is stuck how I could take now
what do I want to do
this pond going I guess this going I
should have probably just immediately
doubled up there I'd like to get my
queen in 2d six the Queen's gonna go to
be four maybe I should have pushed that
sooner okay now my queen is very active
I've Queen Queen to d8 stuff or even
like I have checks and stuff don't I
like right now this is gonna be it's one
accurate move I'm needin right here is
okay thanks i'll pawn push coming up
Wayne check I here and i have pond push
Queen checks right here in fact there's
like Queen sax take that Queen my mouse
is so stupid it constantly slips off the
pad here okay that won't be the last
time I make reference to it either ok
good game striker let me back up here
that was weird what a weird game let's
back up here we go so what's the story
here we call this let me call it what
name are they giving it here they're
calling it after knight c6 here they're
calling it the kovetz traj Kovac defense
actually let me give me some feedback on
the stream are you able to see the name
of the opening just barely on that right
hand side believe I adjusted it enough
so that you could see it a little bit
hi you go saying yes you could see it
okay yeah thanks for the feedback on
that so uh okay cool ok anyhow so I
should have always had that but all
right um so I guess in short if there's
one thing to take away from this it's to
already be quashed be cautious what I
think it's not even a tournament quashes
cautious how do i get a cue out of that
one castles as soon as that mu happens
be cautious of this night just moving in
the bishop having a tough time as a you
know well i mean i got like I can still
see this because this is a threat and
you know what what made me think of this
I think I actually ended up in the same
situation before and i ended up
regretting not chopping this night
sooner so i think that's the main thing
because i'm pretty sure i stand better
right now even if you somehow manage to
save the bishop I think he'll end up
like stuck on a 7 and just be biting at
my pond that really can't be broken down
now granted I did not play the correct
moves here what I should have done is
well you know what I'm still into a
little bit of a problem here aren't I
because if i take the night you
recapture and i play see 5 you still
have a four so it's still a bit messy
isn't it hmm not so clear oh I don't
know interesting game and I'm glad I
didn't grab this Bishop that's a matin
to Queen g5 Queen g2 let's not do that
so
maybe maybe you should take the pawn or
something i don't i don't know it's
tough to recommend anything i'm just
kind of zipping through the moves we
know the moves but i'm not really able
to offer a whole lot am I no not at all
I don't know I don't know what more to
say than good game I I don't know
where's their improvement in the in the
opening part opening part it's an
interesting line you're not just losing
a piece there huh 94 maybe I could have
done something different now I don't
know really don't know okay I'm not
always gonna have something decent to
offer none none takes takes the bishop
in well maybe maybe there isn't a rush
with my playing pawn push in fact no
wait hang on I could still push I could
push again but maybe I should hold off
with this push right here there's no
rush with that if I do this then this
move is available maybe throwing a
question to this Bishop first would play
a role in some way pawn push Bishop back
maybe pawn push again and then I take
the night or take the bishop and press
here so maybe that's an adjustment for
me and so I believe this is something to
still be staying out of the way of is
black but anyhow I think that this would
be an improvement not being more patient
on my end with the c5 moving inserting
an h3 maybe even g4 okay let me close
out good game striker